dalvin cook may have to do the same the
question becomes
moving forward if the vikings attitude
is look we've made our offer it is what
it is and you either continue to play
under the final year of your rookie deal
or you take what we have on the table
will he be inclined
to hold himself out of games if he's
banged you know running backs are always
banged up and this is where
we get into that realm of can you still
play
yes but you don't have long-term
security so that incremental risk of a
serious injury that happens when you
play with an injury he's not willing to
accept that yeah that may be something
the vikings have to deal with this year
so we may see some weeks potentially
where it's the alexander madison show
which gives the vikings a chance to make
the decision you know what we got this
guy under contract through 2022 we'll
just stick with madison if it comes down
to it next year so it's a dangerous game
if cook plays it i think so giving his
backup a chance to show what he can do
and maybe he can do as much or more than
dalvin cook no doubt about it especially
with you know
the run centric you know approach that
zimmer and kubiak want to take and and
you know i would think that's part of
the reason why cook's there mike i think
he realizes he's smart enough to go damn
that guy behind me is really damn good
he rips off you know 1300 yards in a
year where i'm not there that's not
going to be good for my reputation
so dalvin cook is
in a different position than some of the
other running backs we've seen in this
position over the last few years where
you know le'veon bell you know that
situation hey there was nobody else in
pittsburgh he was the guy so yeah he
held out and whatever else but he was
the guy he had the team you know he had
their feet over the fire ezekiel elliott
we were last year going damn they don't
sign ezekiel who the hell are they gonna
play at running back i mean they're
gonna play this rookie you know i mean
you know so it got to that derrick henry
it's a similar situation
that's not the situation in minnesota
and that hurts alvin cook and i don't
like to say that but i do think it
forces his hand a little bit uh to have
to play because of the talent of the guy
that's there next to him so you know
hopefully in his way
he could just be happy to share carries
this year and do things like that and
not totally crush his body with 300 plus
carries or something to where he can
still be fresh and have a career into
his second contract and capitalize off
that because he is grossly underpaid
right now for
you know the class of running back he's
in you know you could argue he's better
than le'veon bell right now right
le'veon bell making that money david
johnson you're gonna argue definitely
better than david johnson as we sit here
right now so there's a class of guys in
front of him where he's looking at and
going damn that's screwed up i'm better
than them and i'd like to get paid but i
don't think it's going to happen here
both however are cautionary tales for
the vikings david johnson got the
contract that tied the cardinals hands
to the point where they weren't going to
be able to get rid of him he had a 10
million dollar guaranteed salary this
year the guarantee vested last year
their hands were tied the fact that they
were able to get any value for him as
part of that deandre hopkins trade is
amazing and the le'veon bell contract i
mean the jets wouldn't do that again if
they had no they would not adam gates
didn't want to do it in the first place
they got they got conned to a certain
extent i'm not saying that in a
pejorative way
they allowed themselves to think that
the ravens were at the table with a
similar offer and they weren't yes they
were not and the jets got squeezed into
paying le'veon bell 12 million plus per
year and i think both teams cardinals
with johnson jets with bell have remorse
for that after the fact and i think the
vikings don't want to be in that spot
that's the problem that's the challenge
and when you look at what melvin gordon
got when he finally reached the open
market chris you know the reality is
your best chance to get big money as a
running back is with the team that you
already were playing for it's hard to
get it on the open market because these
other teams don't want to be the next
team where everyone's saying i told you
so right and it seems like with most of
these running back contracts we're just
you know seven eight nine ten months
away from saying i told you so yeah so
uh that's the challenge and with
alexander madison there who had more
yards per carry last season than dalvin
cook and i know that that's not
necessarily indicative of overall
running back worth right shows his
potential to what you're saying you know
and there it is there it is with 4.6
yards per carry for alexander madison
four and a half for dalvin cook
and and look dalvin cook had 37
receiving yards per game madison only
had 6.3 receiving yards per game but
it's that kubiak style that went from
terrell davis to orlando's gary to mike
anderson thousand yards thousand yards
thousand yards just one guy goes down
put another guy in and there and this is
the reality of the position the supply
far outweighs the demands i remember
coming to this conclusion 15 years ago
watching the west virginia games every
week we go to the home games and every
year there's a guy
who generates 13 14 1500 rushing yards
for west virginia and and he he looks
the part he could play in the nfl he's
got the build he's got the speed he's
got the toughness he's got everything
you need
and every major college has a guy like
that every year and there's only 32 nfl
teams yeah and a lot of teams already
have their starting running backs so
there's plenty of guys that can do that
job and what happens is we get caught up
in the name we get caught up in the
fantasy numbers we get caught up in the
touchdowns we get caught up in the fame
that goes along with the guy having 137
yards rushing in two touchdowns on a
sunday night and
yeah and there's another guy on the
roster who could do the same damn thing
and there's a guy out there available on
the street who could do the same damn
thing and and i don't mean to take
anything away from the skill set but the
reality is there's a lot of guys that
can do that yeah there is and sometimes
in a in a business like the nfl you have
to acknowledge it and you have to just
go with it and that's what the vikings
seem to be doing in attaching a price to
doubt we are going to draft as i said
yeah go ahead i just want to ask you
like if you're a running back you're in
dalvin cook's situation right i mean
it's something i've thought about before
right and here you are
yeah we know you're getting there to the
point of your career where yeah a little
wear and tear on your tires but you're
also getting close to finally making
some real real money and life-changing
family changing type money you know if
you're him
would you rather go
you know what
like hey minnesota just give me the ball
this year and let me have a ton of you
know touches and let me see if i can be
the rushing leader and really put the
squeeze on somebody out there in free
agency or minnesota to where you have to
pay me or would you go hey minnesota you
know coach zimmer you know i'd like to
split the carries more with you know
alexander madison this year just take a
little wear and tear off i think it
might give me another year or two in my
career to where i can collect some money
there and that way and instead of you
know him having 250 carries like last
year and madison having a hundred maybe
they meet somewhere in the middle you
know what i mean at 150 or 175 or
something around there
i i just find it curious what would your
approach be
well i think given his history yeah torn
acl week four of his rookie season not a
real big issues in his second year right
last year was the first year he really
arrived on the scene in the nfl and he
had 1100 rushing yards good but not
spectacular
i would want
to emulate derek henry from last time go
for it yeah okay and go for it yeah and
go for it right because look derek henry
had to become the nfl rushing leader and
it still took months to get the contract
that he had earned by doing so because
the thing is
running backs are always getting paid
for what they've done yes they rarely
get paid for what they're going to do
when have we ever seen except for jared
mckinnon jared mckinnon is the one guy
who got paid for what the 49ers thought
he was going to do yeah and what
happened yeah he still hasn't played in
a game for the 49ers because he injured
his knee in a practice a week before the
start of the 2018 season and then they
had to do it all over again with the acl
last year because it just didn't heal
right he's the one guy remember when
they paid him we were like holy crap
jerick mckinnon's never done anything
he got paid on the way up most of these
guys get paid on the plateau or the way
down but but that's what that's what
derek henry was able to do and i think
about if i'm dabbing cook i said i'm
just going for it yeah i'm going to
force these people to pay me i'm going
to prevent them from letting me walk
away
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports